today president joe biden is expected to  lay out a new strategy to try and stop  the spread of the coronavirus a six-part  strategy is reported it would focus on  increasing vaccination rates improving  covet 19 health care keeping schools  open and protecting the economy a source  familiar with the president's new plan  tells cbs news it will include some kind  of an update on booster shots  some of that will be related to access  to testing some will be related to  mandates some will be related to how we  ensure kids are protected in schools we  have more work to do and we are still at  war with the virus  you'll remember three months ago  president biden hoped the summer would  be free from the coronavirus and its  deadly grip but the delta variant and  vaccine hesitancy has allowed covid19 to  continue to surge